Good afternoon everyone, thank you for coming
to the Advanced Use of NCBI APIs webinar.
Immediately pressing questions will be answered
by my colleague, Peter Cooper during in the
webinar.
And more general questions will be answered
by me at the end of the webinar.
Answers to these questions will be on our
webinars page in addition to questions we
may not get to.
Also the slides are available at the URL that
you see at the bottom of this box.
So, I know most of you are fairly technically
sophisticated, but at some point I think we
are all biologists.
In that vein, what I want to do is to show
you tools and strategies, that I employ to
use NCBI API and FTP infrastructure, to answer
large-scale biological questions.
Say I was interested in age-related molecular
degeneration.
A place I might start asking questions about
macular degeneration is ClinVar.
In case you don't know, ClinVar is a crowd-sourced
database from the clinical genetics community
where they have asserted genotypes that are
associated with specific phenotypes such as
age-related macular degeneration.
If I were to use ClinVar and was interested
in one disease or one snp or a smal set of
them, I might in the search box and narrow
down by the filters on the left.
However as a computational biologist, what
I find useful is to click on the FTP tab and
go to the ClinVar FTP site.
That will bring me to this site, and what
some people miss is that I can get vcf for
either GRCh38 or GRCh37 right now.
This is a 30 MB download, and it has all of
the snps that are in clinvar.
Most of the metadata that is on the website
is included in column 9 of the vcf and can
be filtered as such.
The fields there should be reasonably obvious.
A common use case for those involved in clinical
genetics, when you may have vcf file, for
a given patient or a set of patients with
number of variants, sometimes variants are
expressed in HGVS notation.
This can be ambiguous, so one thing I suggest
is that they use NCBI variation services API,
for disambiguating HGVS.
If that is something you are interested in
please check out this URL, https://api.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/variation/v0/
and give this API a shot.
ClinVar records can now be shown on a viewer
we have called iCn3D.
This service is in alpha, but perhaps it would
be useful to you.
I encourage you to check it out, all you have
to do is re-create this URL,
https://api.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/Structure/icn3d2/seq.html?id=809237
with the ID of the particular structure that
you are interested in viewing.
If it is in the PDB, you will be able to view
snps from clinvar on the structures.
Finally, it is possible that your snps are
not phenotypically characterized.
And in an event I will tell you about in a
bit, we built a tool called PhenVar, and that
tool allows for phenotypic characterization
of snps from dbSNP.
I want to demonstrate that to you now.
If I open up a web browser and I go to phenvar.colorado.edu,
what I can do, and I find this quite exciting,
is I can put in a particular snp, the rs number,
and generate some things I will show you as
well is doing some normalization.
Here, I am doing a live search of PhenVar
and initially I get a word cloud of phenotypes,
phenotypic terms in fact.
These are all of the phenotypic terms co-mentioned
with that snp in PubMed abstracts.
Below I get something perhaps even more useful.
This is a graph of the requested rs ID, linked
to articles, and then a view to other rs IDs
linked to those articles.
If you are familiar with GWAS studies, you
are probably not terribly surprised by this
result.
As you can see, there are a lot of snps associated
with diseases in particular studies that don't
map to others.However there are other snps
which seem to be fairly central to a number
of disease studies.
I would like to demo PhenVar for a snp such
as this, in fact 800292.
So if I search for 800292 under the same parameters,
I get a very similar word cloud, and amd is
even more central.
By the way this is Age-Related Macular Degeneration,
and I see several terms related to Age-Related
Macular Degeneration.
One thing I see here is that I get a much
much denser graph, it is much denser of snps
and publications related to this thing.
Here, I can see lots of publications that
are linked to this snp, 800292 and then other
publications that are a little more flung,
as we can see I have a much more dense network,
of phenotype-genotype associations.
I would like to point out, this was built
using NCBI infrastructure.
One of the pieces of infrastructure used to
build this is EDirect and also Eutils.
One thing I find very useful is the EDirect
cookbook which we built about a year ago.
We hypothesized that people might use commands,
simple commands directly from the Internet
to do relatively complex metadata investigation.
We find this is a popular way to do this.
Say you were interested in all genes aliases
associated with a particular disease in a
particular organism, you could run a query
such as "liver cancer AND homo sapiens" and
find all of the relevant gene aliases.
There are also many similar things you can
do and I encourage you to check it out.
Towards the bottom of this list, there are
a bunch of resources for parsing literature
as well.
I would like to think Mike Davidson as well
as Peter Cooper for working on this project.
Finally.
If there are Edirect queries that you would
like to know how to do, and you cannot figure
them out yourself, please put in issue in
github, at this repository and we will try
to help you out.
I will tell you about some other tools we
use to do more complex things.
In that sense a lot of these tools are built
on something that week call Magic-BLAST.
This effectively allows you to edge computing
on NCBI's SRA database.
The reason it allows you to do that is because
you can do affinities searches, in real-time
without moving the primary data sets.
If you are interested in doing that.
Please check out this URL, https://ncbi.github.io/magicblast
and think about downloading NCBI magic blast.
The resources I am about to show you show
you, EDirect or Eutils, and magicblast are
typically pillars that we have used to stand
up these tools and may be useful when you
are generating your scripts for your tools.
One thing we have been able to do is figure
out how to call SNPs on the fly.
What we do in this pipeline is we use Eutils
to go into dbSNP, and find the flanking regions
for that snp, we then quickly create databases
from the regions of these SNPs, and we blast
SRA objects into them without doing any file
dumping.
This is streaming data.
We further use that to create robots that
are able to go into remote SRA locations,
or even to remote fastq files, look for particular
sets of SNPs, and then anonymize them by random
flipping.
Finally, we use this technology to integrate
phenotypes and genotypes estimating the phenotypic
relatedness by random forest models, and the
genotypic components by feedforward neural
networks.
I would like to point out, this is all based
on magic blast and Eutils infrastructure for
being able to do these technically complicated
things.
We are also able to do novel virus discovery
using these types of things.
This is an early prototype we used to do novel
virus discovery, unfortunately it really required
doing some data dumping.
Now we are able, by leveraging magic blast,
to do discovery without data dumping.
One of the coolest parts of this is not only
can we assemble magic blast hits not only
by MEGAHIT, but Abyss, MetaSpades and assess
protein domains in them, we can create an
algorithm which is analogous to a De Bruijn
graph method where we actually extend the
contigs using magic blast streaming data from
SRA to detect whether there are domains of
other organisms around these viral contigs.
What that lets us do is to see if we have
novel endogenous viruses.
A lot of people contributed to this project
and Jan Buckman in my group is continusing
it wrapping this in Python currently.
We are also able to use magic blast for antibiotic
resistance detection.
This is a simple method, a very simple method
to detect antibiotic resistance genes in public
genomic databases and datasets such as those
in the SRA.
Effectively what it does, it removes host
genetic material using Magic-BLAST, and then
uses magic blast to map the CARD database
to the resulting read sets.
It then produces a graph of these things.
This was just published in the journal F100
Research and the program is called nasty bugs.
Finally, just last week we prototyped something
we call deSRA.
what deSRA allows researchers to do is put
in individual gene IDs and a list of SRR accessions,
and through Magic-BLAST, we computed some
blast database, we were able to approximate
expression for any genes in a particular SRA
data set.
That is something that I think is exciting
because it gives an initial screening tool
to any raw, RNA-seq data set on the web.
I would like to think the team that built
this, some of whom are listening to the webinar
right now.
Why is Magic-BLAST able to stream things from
the SRA?
That has to do with the SRA toolkit infrastructure.
Basically the toolkit allows for data streaming
from the SRA data sets.
You can use these tools as they are right
now.
They do many things.
Here are some more complex ones, these are
simple ones.
You can also integrate these into your code
and they have been integrated into both HISAT2
as well as GATK.
So you can use those tools directly with NCBI,
SRA data sets.
I highly recommend you check out some of these
URLs for further information.
Finally a lot of these things were built in
NCBI Hackathons, or originally prototyped
in NCBI Hackathons.
Here is a list of upcoming Hackathons, and
a live URL where you can find these.
I will also add the publication for NastyBugs
very soon as well as some recent prototypes
we've worked on.
Other projects were worked on or extended
in the NCBI visiting bioinformaticians program.
If you are interested in coming to work at
NCBI for 4 to 6 weeks as an individual bioinformatician,
please email this alias for more information.
bioinformatics-training@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
Thank you very much.
And with that I will take questions.
Somebody asked, is there a way to sign up
for a hackathon, it is not clear on the website?
On the screen I showed you, there were no
live links, but if you go to the site, as
it is now, some of the events have live links,
those will direct you to sign-up pages for
those events.
Please email this alias if you have any questions
about the hackathons.
Somebody asked what experimental catalyst
is, the name has changed, but it is effectively
an alpha prototype for being able to document
both wet and dry bench lab work, in a visual,
Python framework.
Someone else asked, they are interested in
meta data, is it possible to all metadata
associated with a BioSample or BioProject?
For example the source of isolation for bacteria.
The answer is absolutely, and it's really
quite trivial.
I highly recommend that you Google for the
EDirect cookbook.
There are specific examples on how to get
in to the metadata, the kind that you are
interested in for biosamples and bioprojects
of different bacteria.
What you can do is get the XML, for the whole
biosample record, there is an NCBI specific
XML parser called xtract, that will parse
the metadata up from the XML for you.
So someone asked about the Magic-BLAST procedure.
What I would say is, Magic-BLAST if you are
used to command line BLAST it is very similar
with just a couple of caveats.
For one thing it is optimized for next generation
sequencing, that said, it will output by default
to the SAM File, although you can get tabular
output as well.
Just look at the help document.
The binary can easily be downloaded from either
the NCBI BLAST Page, or from the github page
I showed you.
Someone asks what languages most of these
tools are created in?
They are created in some combination of bash,
R, and Python.
Someone else asked about analysis of snps
that cause alternative splicing, and gathering
information through the SRA Toolkit.
That is a fairly difficult thing to do as
a whole, but one could envision building a
tool for that.
One thing you might be interested in doing
is taking RefSeq RNA, and building a blast
database from your RefSeq RNA of interest.
Then you can blast into the database, and
look for relative abundance of spliced isoforms
as well is snps of those in the RNA.
That is something that you can do relatively
easily through Magic-BLAST.
It is great to see there are a lot of questions.
Are there any other questions?
I will give it another minute or two.
Actually, someone else said does Magic-BLAST
also work for assemblies?
I'm not entirely sure what you mean, but you
could use Magic-BLAST for whole genomes, it
does work and it has very similar characteristics
to HISAT.
Depending on what you are looking at, you
might want to try both Magic-BLAST and HISAT
for transcript mapping.
You can also use MagicBLAST in non-splice
mode to do DNA-seq mapping.
Someone asked what tools we are using for
contig assembly?
I suspect you are talking about the novel
virus searching?
Right now we are testing metaSPAdes, ABySS
2 as well as megaHIT.
If you have further suggestions, please feel
free to send bioinformatics-training an email.
Also for specific applicaations, although
not so much for metagenomics, we are using
NCBI-built assembler called Skeesa, which
is freely available.
If you are interested, I am giving a very
very short NCBI minute on Skeeza on November
29.
If you want to hear about some of the contigs
we've generated from bacterial pathogen data
sets. with SKEZA, please check that out.
If you are interested in the Hackathons, we
are giving a workshop on running NCBI- NIH-style
Hackathon's, I believe on December on December
10, but that is just off the top of my head;
it is a Friday.
Someone asked what Data Portal might be useful
to study population-based cancer genomics
data?
I'd encourage you to check out TCGA, which
is a large set of data put out by NCI, and
dbGaP also has quite a bit of cancer genomics
data, for some cancers, quite a bit more than
TCGA.
We have provided a very short command line
tool to go between the TCGA and dbGaP data
set accessions for particular diseases.
All right great with that I think we will
leave it here.
I would like to think everyone for attending
and I hope you have a fantastic rest of your
week.